luke here with the outdoor boys youtube
channel and today
we're building a fishing boat but not
just
any fishing boat we're building a
fishing boat for less than 120
using only tools and materials you can
find anywhere
i'm going to build a coracle boat now
what's a coracle boat you ask
it's a traditional boat found all over
the world
that's made using woven wood and
waterproof skins
the first time i ever saw a coracle boat
i was on a safari in southwest
india and when i was going down the
kabini river we were in
a giant woven basket coracle boat and i
said this
is so cool i have got to build one of
these well now 14 years later here i am
i'm gonna build a coracle boat but i'm
gonna do it
the american way we're gonna build
another boat
wait wait wait you're gonna build
another boat you already have
eight boats eight boats that doesn't
seem right
seven hours later
okay a boat becca boats
are like shoes you could never have too
many
don't mind if i do
remember guys rookies buy chocolates and
flowers if you want to get something
done right
you buy shoes
[Music]
[Music]
well getting to this point in the
project was a lot of work i had to redo
the back of the boat
three times and i learned something
really important the back
lower corners of the boat have to be
rounded without rounded corners
you can't get the ribs to fit inside the
boat
additionally i learned that you have to
take some sort of piece of wood
and zip tie it across the middle top of
the boat
to help it keep its shape while you're
building the boat
otherwise each time you add a rib the
boat gets more
and more out of shape and eventually try
to just lay flat like a plate
[Music]
i did a lot of experimentation to try to
figure out the best way to connect
pvc pipe what turned out to be the best
was taking the heat gun and
flattening the end of the pvc pipe then
drilling a hole
and then using a zip tie
hands down the most time consuming part
of this entire project
was using the heat gun it was about 15
minutes to heat up the pvc pipe
mold it to the proper shape and then
cool it down and this had to be done
multiple times
on a single piece of pipe each one of
the ribs
was custom shaped and unique
yeah okay um if i can make me
the zombie basin is actually still
happening
look at this i didn't care i still tried
i'll put the bumpy side on the inside
there was over 900 zip ties used in this
boat so i spent a lot of time
zipping and clipping cable ties this
looks like a proper little row boat
[Applause]
oh my god
[Music]
[Applause]
because
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i want all the zip ties to stay in place
and not slide around so i've got a
little bit of this
pvc spray adhesive
you can use just about anything
waterproof to cover your boat i ended up
using this tarp
but i've seen people use canvas soaked
in tar plastic bags and i even
considered using
the heat shrink they winterized boats
with
ah
it's people
wow that looks legit
[Music]
ah
[Applause]
ah
well she floats like a cork but that's
because i ain't in it i'm not sure
what's gonna happen when i put 250
pounds of me
inside this thing i'm really concerned
it's just going to fold up and sink down
so this is going to be exciting
nothing for it oh that's
tippy no matter what happens becca know
that i loved you
okay watch out boys do you think becca
is it is it working
i think it's working i'm trying to swim
away
i don't feel any spongebob to you
hey guys do you want to come ride in the
rowboat
all right step in towards the middle you
can't step onto the wood
or jump what happens if we all die don't
remarry
jacob did you want to come too whoa
and try and lift you to daddy oh there
you go
right there okay well we have 350 pounds
of boy
in here and uh we seem to be doing okay
it's a little tippy but it's not bad
all right let's see if i can get out
without
flipping
well guys i think that worked well we've
tried the boat out and it works but now
we need to break it in and to do that we
need to catch
some fish in it because that's what
boats were meant for
so we're gonna go out and try to catch a
big old carp or catfish out of this
thing
and uh my wife thought of a nice name
for it
she was trying to refer to it as the
thing you do and accidentally called it
the dingy do
and i think that is that is perfect
becca's going to be driving the pontoon
boat
so that she can fill me here so
hopefully we'll give her something to
film
other than me drowning
[Music]
hey dad why are you so slow
i should be on crew
[Laughter]
all right well the sun is setting really
quickly and
i've got a long ways to go so i am
contemplating
having the boat tow me this will be
really sketchy
we're going a little faster
that poor woman is having to film drive
and fight children
look at me sure i'm the captain now
well you know now i'm just sitting in
this boat i'm noticing it's
you know it's doing pretty good don't
have a lot of water in the boat
and uh this tarp does well that pipe
right there seems a little
a little scawampus
all right here babe that's good okay
i'm gonna put this in my rod holder over
here that one's got a hook
put that one over there
i think we got a chance of pulling in
some big big fish today we'll see what
happens
we're going to be fishing for carp and
catfish today so i've got a pack bait
that works
excellent for both it's strawberry jello
panko bread crumbs and sweet corn mixed
up into kind of a doughy bait
and i've got it packed under what's
called a method lead and i've got a
little hair rig
with a fake piece of plastic corn
you know i cut these rod holders into
the boat but they're really unnecessary
i can just stick my rod anywhere i want
oh look at that
look at that look at that
it is a little baby channel catfish
that's a little
tinker yeah that that barely hit the
water and they came in
all right becca's anchored up right over
there so she can help fill me and tell
search and rescue where i went down
don't remarry well guys the sun is just
set
and it's getting properly dark now's the
magic time
all right becca hit the lights
oh he popped off oh man that felt like a
carp
well it wasn't exactly what we were
looking for but we weren't
skunked and the dinghy do caught a dinky
little fish which i guess is kind of
appropriate
but it is now officially a fishing boat
well that was fun but i want to improve
things a little bit first off i think we
need to put an engine
on the back of this boat so i'm going to
modify it slap an engine on the back
and try this again
[Applause]
oh
uh
foreign
we're back here at the park and we are
gonna try our new and improved
motorized coracle boat
i got rid of the rod holder and man it
just makes it a whole lot easier to take
it on and off the roof rack now
this wooden bar right here is missing
that was really important when i first
made the boat
because the pvc pipe ribs wanted to go
and spread out like this
and so that bar was helping the boat
keep its shape but after it sat in my
front yard for a couple days in like 90
plus degree heat in full sun
the pvc pipe heated up and then relaxed
and so now it keeps its shape
without the spreader bar which is great
because now it's just so much more room
and it makes it a lot easier to get on
and off the top of the car
let's give it a try
what i really need to do is fabricate
some sort of tiller arm extension
so i can operate it out here to the side
instead of straight over my shoulder
we're not breaking any land speed
records but we are moving
and this boat gets a lot more stable
when it's actually uh
moving at a couple miles per hour it's
kind of like riding a bicycle
well one nice thing about this setup is
i am so much stealthier than that
pontoon boat i'm gonna sneak right up on
these fish well that didn't take long
got a nice little hit going on right
here
oh that is the tiniest little channel
catfish
let him go
yeah we got something on here
there you go not a big channel catfish
but at least this one you could
technically eat if i wanted to there we
go
gotta be careful not to drop this thing
and have him poke a hole in the boat
well it's gotten kind of quiet so i
think i might pull up the anchor and
just let the current drift me down to
the other side of the tree and see if
that's any better
slightly bigger channel catfish a little
eater size
look at the spider found he's huge come
on guy holy mackerel
he is massive hop out you can do it
i believe in you well it's getting laid
and i've got to get going home but man
this project's been fun this boat's
quirky it's got some limitations but
gosh darn it it works
and i've caught fish out of it so you
know that's pretty cool
and i hope you guys enjoyed this video
as much as i enjoyed making it
don't forget to click subscribe to the
outdoor boys youtube channel we put out
new videos
every saturday morning if you like this
video don't forget to check out the
outdoor boys youtube channel where we
have hundreds of videos just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
saturday morning
and hit that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching